i almost want to say it's a shame with
magnus's blunder because your defense
prior to that move was unbelievable
uh it was yeah it was desperation i was
thinking it's gonna be a yeah
quick defeat for me was playing so fast
and i didn't know what to do and
there was more desperation than anything
just trying to confuse it a little bit
uh i guess he just missed that i could
take on a two bit maybe he forgot about
your bishop yeah actually i missed it
myself too for a little bit uh so uh
yeah the bishop on g8 it's maybe a
little bit hard to see but um yeah it's
very surprising just like no worse but
but but i'm curious because
the resources you've found now two games
in a row it must even though you get in
very poor position from the beginning
this is about as opposite to the fun
forest we expect to see with its opening
theory games and things like that you're
you're finding resources mid game now
yeah i'm getting surprised in the
opening myself here every game so i have
to change my game plan and the way i
play but
yeah i guess maybe resourcefulness is
one of my strengths it might be
but
i mean to me it just seems like luck at
the moment i didn't i just didn't know
what to do and i thought this might try
might be a try but it felt like it
should be losing for me somehow
thank you so much
so that